today's monday minute is get out of the
office i got a great email from my video
producer christina hey christina she's
watching
who reminded me that you know if all you
need is an internet connection and a
laptop to encourage people to get out of
the office and it's true you know you
can get stuck in a rut doing the same
thing in the same environment and you
can shake things up get new creativity
get new ideas get new motivation new
energy by just getting out of your
office if you can work from a laptop go
work in the garden one day if all you
need is an internet connection go to a
starbucks go to a library just get out
of the office for one day
and shake your routine up just a little
bit to get a little bit more energy
because doing the same thing over and
over and over and over and over and over
again doesn't lead to creativity or
happiness so sometime this week
go and get out of the office and work
from somewhere else believe
like this video leave a comment click on
my face subscribe to the channel i'll
see you soon